the flccc vax injury protocol is out i
have found it helpful please take a look
so i saw this right before we went on
yep i've looked at it um
okay so yeah here it is um this is the
post-vaccine treatment
they say first-line therapies
intermittent fasting ivermectin
low-dose naltrexone i think is how you
pronounce that yeah i can make this
bigger too um
um
melatonin aspirin vitamin c vitamin d
vitamin k2
quercetin and then now for that that's
that's what they've got yeah so i'm not
too far off
so they also their prevention
protocol yeah it has a lot of the same
elements
they also have i think there are two
things on their site called i recover
one of them is long coveted and one yeah
i've actually got that other one open as
well is uh is vaccine injury yeah this
is long cove and it's actually different
it's interesting a the first line
therapies is a little bit different
ivermectin is still on there but
prednisone naltrexone again omega-3
fatty acids vitamin d and then they've
got second line therapies which includes
flavoxamine and
torva statin
um
they've got a lot of stuff on here that
i don't actually recognize including
like four different
successive kinds of
other kinds of treatment but of course
for long covet you might expect you know
there's just lost so many different
amounts of time that people may be
experiencing things yeah
um
well uh there are a number of things
there's one thing on there
i recover from the vaccine
injury protocol
uh there's um
a drug that is typically used to
reduce addiction to opioids so
i don't see that on here you sure no
drexel oh that's what that is the
naltrexone yep okay um
so anyway i've inquired as to what role
that is playing but you know
a number of the things in here are doing
something that is not their
primary yeah well there but there's
something around opioid receptors that
you know one of mid you know
i can't say mid who knows where we are
in this thing but
sometime between
march 2020 and now there was some
discussion of maybe opioid receptors
being involved in
um differential response to code
exposure i think don't remember maybe a
totally different mechanism but you know
we've got aspirin on this protocol
presumably that's as
an anticoagulant not an analgesic
melatonin is on there melatonin has long
been understood to have some benefits in
the context of
covid and
uh that's not
i think it's not through the mechanism
of it allowing you to get more sleep
yeah well it might be related to some of
the stuff we talked about a few episodes
ago with regard to
um
you know the
the benefits of sunlight that aren't
vitamin d include the near-infrared um
exposure that uh basically prompts this
you know this like circulating melatonin
as opposed to the
the form of melatonin that we think of
as being um on a circadian rhythm yep um
i mean i think the overarching reaction
i have is you've got a tiny number of
doctors who have dared
to
experiment and figure out what works for
the patients that they're seeing
and you know i mean we have vaccine
injured friends and we've directed
several of them to these tiny number of
doctors who will actually treat them
how much better off would we be
if medicine in general was trying to
solve this problem and all of these
doctors could pool their knowledge and
talk about things that they've noticed
that work that don't work patterns that
they've seen right it's insane that we
would play this game this way that we
would demonize yep the fl triple c for
daring to
to acknowledge that there are vaccine
injuries into daring to treat these
people
um
so anyway
i guess what i would say is look we've
got a tiny number of experts in this
they're the people who dared
to um admit that there was a problem and
do the job of medicine that involves
trying to figure out how to make these
people's suffering
less yeah um so you know more power too
[Music]